what i would like to do is describe an
imaginary or fictitious bitcoin
transaction and then talk about how
somebody might try to game or defraud
the system and why that's not only
mathematically hard to do but why
there's actually an incentive actually
an economic incentive in the bitcoin
system for different people to behave
honestly
so let's suppose that there is someone
out there named dan and dan wants to
order a pizza maybe a cheese pizza from
pete's pizza shop and let's say the
pizza pizza shop accepts bitcoins as
payment and that it costs one bitcoin
one bitcoin for a
pizza pie
and imagine that dan received previously
let's say he received uh five bitcoins
from his cousin carol so maybe carol
we're going to label by c gave to dan
uh five uh bitcoins
uh which we can
label as a b with a circle around it
and that he wants to use one of these
five bitcoins to buy a pizza from pete
and so what dan's bitcoin client will do
is it will create a transaction record
that includes information about how dan
got these bitcoins so in this case it
includes information about this
transaction between uh carol who we've
marked by c
and dan for five bitcoins and then it
specifies that dan wants to give
one of these bitcoins to pete and label
pete by a p
and also that dan is going to take the
remaining four bitcoins and
that will be basically change to himself
and the way that bitcoin is built is
that you have to actually specify
the change because you need to have a
way whatever goes into the bitcoin
system has to kind of come out at the
other end and so you can't have a
transaction where the numbers don't add
up and so whatever is remaining
is either change or part of it can be
used as a transaction fee and so on but
for this example to keep things simple
i'll assume that there is no transaction
fee in place the transaction fee is just
zero and we'll focus only on the
situation in which
everything is being accounted for in the
transaction
now this transaction record is going to
be broadcast out to the entire bitcoin
world and so in particular uh pete is
going to receive a copy of this
transaction but in addition to pete
receiving it
so too will
uh the other people on the on the
bitcoin system and and if you recall
there are these special nodes these
special entities or people in bitcoin
that are known as bitcoin miners and
these bitcoin miners are going to be
responsible for
making sure that everything checks out
in the transaction from a global
perspective what they do is they look at
the full record of transactions and this
transaction record is public it's known
as the the transaction blockchain and
i've kind of put a description of the
transaction blockchain right here
and this transaction blockchain can take
the history of every single
transaction that's ever occurred within
the bitcoin system from the beginning of
time the time of the first block which
is known in bitcoin as the genesis block
okay and everybody can verify that uh
the details of any transaction if they
want to because that information is
public and in particular what these
bitcoin miners will look at is they'll
look at whether or not uh dan previously
received five bitcoins from from anybody
else in this particular case it was his
cousin carol
uh whether or not uh dan has tried to
spend those bitcoins previously and so
on and so forth
and
these bitcoin miners are all
collectively trying to take all these
recent transactions that haven't yet
been recorded
and that includes not only the
transaction between uh dan and pete but
there may be other transactions floating
out there that took place around the
same time and the bitcoin miners will
basically look at all these different
transactions at once
and they're going to basically try to
figure out how to form a transaction
block
out of these transactions and they want
to add this transaction block to the end
of the current transaction blockchain
now if you might recall from previous
videos that for a bitcoin miner to add a
transaction block to a transaction
blockchain they have to solve what's
known as a proof-of-work puzzle and the
bitcoin system is designed or maybe
calibrated as a better word so that on
average one miner will solve a puzzle in
about 10 minutes
now i think it's actually worth
stressing here that it could take a long
time for any one individual miner to
solve the puzzle it could even take
maybe a year or even two years
but because there are so many
of these miners
working at the same time
one of them is bound to get lucky and
solve the puzzle quickly
now each puzzle
in the
proof of work each of these
proof-of-work puzzles
that is associated with a transaction
block
happens to have a difficulty score
associated with it and this difficulty
basically represents how hard it was to
solve that proof-of-work puzzle
and so imagine that there are some
numbers and we'll call these numbers
uh let's say the
we'll call them d sub n for the most
recent difficulty score they'll be d sub
n minus one these are just numbers that
somehow represent
how hard it was
to solve this proof of work
and when you look at an overall chain
what the bitcoin system is interested in
is it's interested in how hard was it to
construct that entire chain
and the reason it's important for
someone to understand how hard the
entire chain was constructed is because
this this overall score for this chain
this difficulty score for the chain
is what's used
by peter by other people who are
receiving bitcoins
to
figure out whether or not they trust
that transaction the more work that went
into the overall chain the more trust
they'll have in that transaction
and the reason for that is that the way
bitcoin works is that if there was ever
more than one transaction blockchain out
there let's say there was
a bad user out there or maybe somebody
didn't receive a particular message in
time or whatever reason if there's
somehow more than one transaction
blockchain out there
according to the bitcoin protocol
everyone is just supposed to work off of
the chain that had the most work put
into it so we ignore
chains that are that have a lot less
work and only consider the chain that
had the most work put into it and in the
bitcoin
system that particular chain is often
referred to as the longest
the longest chain in the system and this
is actually kind of a confusing
confusing piece of terminology because
by longest here we don't mean
that this chain is long in any physical
sense we really just mean and i'm going
to put a three equal bars to kind of say
what it means by the longest chain we
mean the chain that has the most
most work and and the way that the work
is defined is that you look at all these
different difficulty scores
and these are difficulty numbers and you
add them up and that gives you a
difficulty score for the entire chain
and now we're going to be interested in
the chain that had the most work put
into it and we call that the longest
chain now let's imagine that dan is
dishonest and that after
he eats the pizza let's say pete's
convinced and he gives
he gets his bitcoin from dan he waits a
bit he sees that there's a long chain
out there that contains a transaction
he sends the pizza over to dan
dan eats the pizza and then decides that
he
doesn't want to behave honestly and he
wants to somehow cheat pete or he wants
to defraud the system
and the way that dan is going to try to
defraud the system is
by attempting to create another
transaction in which he assigns the five
bitcoins he got from carol
uh to somebody else and it could be uh
we're gonna let's call this person fred
and let's say fred is basically you know
fred could be dan's alter ego it could
be a friend of dan's uh doesn't matter
who fred is because we know that fred
isn't the rightful owner of these
bitcoins but what dan is gonna try to do
is he's gonna try to take
those five bitcoins that he got from
carol
and he's gonna now try to take those
five bitcoins and assign them over to
fred
and we know that this is something that
we don't want
to allow because
that would mean that somehow dan was
able to spend these five bitcoins twice
over he's effectively double spent those
bitcoins and obviously one of these
transactions
should be considered fraudulent the
other one
should be allowed to go through
now it's important to keep in mind that
if dan just tried to spend these same
coins again without trying to cover his
tracks or
anything of that nature then everybody
out there would know that dan is up to
no good because they can see
from the existing longest transaction
blockchain uh namely this existing chain
from the beginning they can see that hey
dan already spent these coins before he
shouldn't be allowed to spend these
coins again
and so what dan has to do is actually
on his own he has to create a different
transaction blockchain
that contains just the second bogus
transaction in it
and this would be the transaction to
fred and they would leave out the other
transaction to pete
and hope that everybody else will start
to accept or believe this newer chain
and remember that since everyone in
bitcoin ultimately goes with the
transaction chain that contains the most
work namely this this longest chain that
we talked about
dan has a fighting chance he has a
hope potentially of
being able to pull off this type of a
of a fraudulent scheme and the real
question now is how likely is it for dan
to succeed
so for dan to be able to pull this off
he has to
start off with the transaction
blockchain that existed previously and
he has to try to add to that transaction
blockchain a different transaction so
rather than having this previous
transaction where
he gave money to to pete he's going to
try to create
a new transaction and add to the
transaction blockchain that contains
this other uh fraudulent transaction
between
between dan
and his friend fred
okay so this is going to be the the bad
transaction between dan and fred will be
in this new this new block
and in bitcoin lingo this idea is known
as a fork in the chain and all we mean
by a fork is that somehow there is uh
more than one version of history
somebody tried to rewrite their tracks
or to cover their tracks into to revise
history the way we know it
and what that really means is there's
now somehow more than one version of
what happened out there so in this
example
one branch in this fork is legitimate
and the other branch is bogus and the
legitimate branch was the one in our
minds where dan paid his friend peter
this this vendor pete for a pizza and
the bogus one is this follow-on
transaction where dan attempted to
pay his friend fred with those same
exact bitcoins but now remember that any
transaction block that's added to this
transaction blockchain has to contain
within it a proof-of-work puzzle
or a solution rather to a proof-of-work
puzzle otherwise no one will accept the
chain and so if dan wants to cheat the
system he has to secretly
solve
a new proof-of-work puzzle himself
but the challenge for dan is that he's
starting off at a bit of a handicap
because there's already this longer
chain out there
that
people have started accepting and keep
in mind that because this chain is out
there other nodes may have started to
build on top of this chain every 10
minutes
somebody's adding to this chain
on average and so there's this longer
transaction blockchain out there and dan
wants to create his own fake chain and
so he has to create a chain
in order for that chain to be believable
it has to now be the longest chain out
there and he has to basically do
all these proof of works to create a
chain that is longer
and to come up with this longer chain on
his own dan has to outrun the existing
proof of work chain and that means he
has to solve not just typically one
proof-of-work puzzle but he may need to
solve uh several proof-of-work puzzles
to create another chain
that he hopes will be longer than the
chain that's out there and if he can get
the longest chain then he can get people
to start using that chain instead and
that's the chain that he might want
people to use because it contains this
fake transaction but it removes the
previous transaction where he gave money
to pete
and to solve a proof of work dan has to
basically take whatever computing power
he has access to
and
he has to start working on solving the
proof of work puzzle
and there are no known shortcuts for
solving these puzzles if you recall from
any of the proof of work videos
to succeed in a proof of work is kind of
like
winning a lottery there are
ways to do it
but it really depends on how much
computing power you have the more
computing power you have access to the
more lottery tickets you have
and if somebody has even one lottery
ticket they do have a chance to win the
lottery but they are far less likely to
succeed compared to somebody who has a
lot of lottery tickets in hand
and even if you succeed once in winning
the lottery with a small number of
tickets the likelihood of repeating that
feat over and over again several times
in a row becomes much smaller but that's
exactly what dan has to do he has to
basically win this lottery multiple
times until he has a bigger chain and so
the key metric here the key thing you
have to look for
is how much computing power dan has
versus how much computing power
all the honest nodes in the system have
together
and if it's the case that all the honest
node let's say we'll call it the honest
the honest computing power and when i
say honest computing power i mean the
total computing power
for all the nodes who are honest all the
bitcoin mining nodes who are honest in
the network
if that total computing power that they
have access to
is greater than the
power that the dan has access to so
dan's computing power
then the bitcoin system will be safe
because it'll be hard for dan to be able
to
create this fraudulent transaction chain
because he won't be able to outrun
the honest people the honest people win
the lottery more frequently and they'll
create a longer chain and dan's
attempt is going to be very much an
uphill battle now it's theoretically
possible that dan could have access to a
lot of computing power maybe he's very
wealthy or he has a lot of resources but
he'll really need a lot to be able to do
that more than everyone else who's
legitimate combined
so that's one aspect of why the
transaction blockchain is secure because
it's unlikely for any one individual to
have access to
just that much computing power and here
i should point out that there is also
another aspect to the security of
bitcoin if dan has access to that kind
of computing power to solve these
proof-of-work puzzles then rather than
trying to fight this uphill battle of
forking the transaction blockchain and
creating fake transactions and so on
dan is probably much better off
just using that computing power he has
for legitimate bitcoin mining himself
you might remember that bitcoin miners
who solve proof-of-work puzzles get both
a reward for succeeding they get some
number of bitcoins and they also get a
transaction fee for all the transactions
in the block that they validated so
there's this economic incentive for dan
to behave honestly and so maybe i should
just recap in closing the video that the
security of bitcoin transactions comes
from first of all this mathematical
barrier that makes it hard for dan to
fork the transaction blockchain in a
dishonest way
as well as an economic incentive for dan
to just act honestly and mine bitcoins
for himself